this right over here is the graph of the
polar function
r is equal to 5 minus 3 sine of theta
what i want to do in this video is think
about what is the slope of the tangent
line
so what is the slope
of the tangent line
tangent line
when
when
theta is equal to 5 pi
over 6. and just so that we can
visualize that when theta is 5 pi over
6. so that's going to be an angle that
looks something like
it's going to look something like this
so
this angle right over here is 5 pi over
6 radians
5 pi over 6 radians this is r of 5 pi
over 6 and i want to figure out the
slope of the tangent line so the tangent
line would look something like this
would look something like this i want to
figure out what is the slope of that
what is
the slope of the tangent line i
encourage you to pause the video and see
if you can figure it out on your own
so i'm assuming you've had a go at it
i'll give you a hint right over here but
and maybe if you get inspired i
encourage you always to pause the video
again and try it out on your own
but one
one or a series of hints is we know when
we're kind of going between polar form
and regular rectangular form
that x
x is going to be equal to r cosine of
theta and y is equal to r
sine of theta
and then i'll give you another hint is
that the slope of the tangent line
that's going to be d y
d x at that point which is going to be
the derivative of y with respect to
theta divided by the derivative of x
with respect to theta and once again you
in literal form you don't really think
of differentials as numerators or
denominators of fractions but they do
tend to work out that way and you notice
that right over here in both the
numerator and denominator you're
dividing by theta and then that
essentially could be conceptualized or
or one way to think about it is that's
the same thing as d y d x you're taking
the rate at which y is changing with
respect to theta divide that by the rate
at which x is changing with respect to
theta and that's going to give you the
rate at which y is changing with respect
to x
so given these hints that i've drawn in
pink maybe another go at it see if you
can figure out the slope of the tangent
line when theta is equal to 5 pi over 6.
so let's just think through it let's
just think through it i will start i
will start with y over here
so
y
y is r sine of theta but we know that r
is 5 minus 3 sine of theta so it's going
to be 5
minus 3 sine
of theta times sine of theta
times sine of theta
and so what's d y d theta
d y
d theta the derivative of y with respect
to theta well let's see we could take
the derivative of this first expression
which is just going to be negative 3
cosine theta negative 3 cosine
theta that's the derivative of that
times the second expression i'm just
doing the product rule over here
times sine of theta and then we're going
to have plus
plus the derivative of the second
expression which is just cosine of theta
cosine of theta
times the first expression
times 5 minus 5 minus 3
3 sine of theta
now let's figure out what d
x d theta is
so
x
x
is equal to
it's r cosine theta r is 5 minus 3 sine
theta
5 minus 3
sine
theta
times cosine theta
times cosine oops i want to do that in
that pink color
times
cosine
theta and so dx d theta
dx the derivative of x with respect to
theta the rate of change of x with
respect to theta once again we just
apply the product rule it's going to be
the derivative of this first expression
which is going to be
negative
3
cosine theta times the second expression
this is once again just
just applying i'm just applying
the i'm just applying the product rule
here and then plus the derivative of the
second expression so it's minus sine
of theta times this first expression so
times
five minus 3
sine of theta
and so now
we can write we can write
d y
dx
is going to be equal to
d y
d theta
over
dx d theta
dx
d theta
which is equal to d y d theta it's all
of this business actually let me just
let me just write it up let me just copy
and paste it so copy and paste so it's
going to be that
and then let me copy and paste the rest
of it so plus that
so copy and paste
plus that
that's our numerator and then our
denominator is going to be all of this
business
all of this
so
copy and paste
so we'll put that in the
denominator so that's a general and this
is pretty neat already this is a general
expression for d y d x which would be
the slope of the tangent line notice it
is a function of theta expressed as a
function of theta so now we just need to
figure out what is this going to be when
theta is 5 pi over 6
and we see a bunch of cosines and sines
of 5 pi over 6. so let's just remind
ourselves what cosine or sine of 5 pi
over 6 is
so
i'll just write it
over in this so sine
of 5
pi over 6. 5 pi over 6 is pi over 6 away
from
the negative x axis so this is going to
be sine of 5 pi over 6 is one half and
cosine
of 5
pi over 6
is negative square root of 3 over 2. and
so we can use that information right
over here so this is going to be equal
to
this is going to be equal to and got to
be careful here let me just
so it's negative 3
times cosine of theta
so negative 3 times cosine 5 pi over 6
is going to be positive 3
square roots of 3 over 2 that's this
part right over here negative times a
negative is a positive
times sine of theta well that's one-half
times
one-half
and then plus
cosine of theta which is negative square
root of three
over two
times
five minus three sine theta three times
sine of theta is three halves or one and
a half five minus one and a half is 3.5
or another way of thinking this is 7
halves
so times
7 halves that's our numerator
now our denominator once again this is a
little bit hairy but we will power
through well negative 3 cosine theta we
already figured out that is 3
square roots of 3
over
2
and then times cosine of theta well
that's going to be a negative that's
going to be another so times negative
square root of 3 over 2. let me do that
same color so we can follow along
actually
so times
negative square root of 3
over 2
minus sine of theta so minus one half
and then all of this business we already
figured out was seven halves
so all of this is seven halves and so
this is going to be equal to let's see
if we can
do this relatively neatly so it's going
to be 3 this part right over here
is 3 square roots of 3
over 4.
this right over here
is
minus
7
square roots of three
over four so what would that be that
would be negative
four square roots of three over four
this is negative four square roots of
three over four or this just simplifies
luckily to
negative square root of 3. now in the
denominator what do we have in the
denominator
we have
this term right over here is going to be
c root of 3 times square root of 3 is 3.
3 times 3 is 9. so it's negative 9
halves negative 9 halves
do that right yep negative oh sorry
negative 9 4. be careful
negative 9 fourths
and then we have to worry about this
right over there
so that's negative
negative seven fourths so minus
seven fourths do i do that right yep
this is negative and then this is
negative as well and so this is going to
be equal to
the denominator here
is going to be equal to
negative 16 4 negative 16 fourths let me
just write that negative 16 fourths
which is going to be equal to
negative four so we have negative square
root of three over negative four
so
we we deserve a bit of a drum roll over
here the negatives cancel out we get
square root of three
square root of three
over four is the slope is the slope
right over here and you can actually see
it it actually makes sense that that
would be the slope of the tangent line
there